Massive "aha" driving down the
road with my brother, Ben. And
realized that something really unique happens
in conversation when you're on a road trip
and that is you're fed all of this data all
around you. So, we just drove by a Marriott
and I talked about the article that I saw that
people were scraping Marriott- was being scraped
off a building so we was wondering, "Did Marriott
go out of business?" Which I don't know if it's
true, maybe we'll fact check that and put a yes
or no here. But then, we drove by IKEA and
started talking about the sustainability of IKEA
and my thought is what would happen if we were to
channel all of the data, the conversational data
that literally flies by at 60 miles an hour on a
road trip. What if we were to channel that into
our conversations even when we were stationary?
Whether it was an elevator or a board meeting or
a classroom or anything else. And in this video,
I'm gonna unpack and share a few ways that I
think that you can make that happen. Here we go.
If you've been following on the channel for
any amount of time, I hope that was fun to kind
of break out of the studio format. This video is
totally inspired by that car trip with my brother,
Ben. And so, we're going to unpack how to bring up
topics in conversation. I'm going to label this
entire video "The Road Trip Method." And I don't know
if anybody's come up for before, I didn't google it
before making this video but we're going to call
it The Road Trip Method and we're going to call
it The Road Trip Method because of the natural
default, I think, when people are on a road trip
or driving in a car to talk about what they see.
All of the data that is surrounding them. Now,
I'm going to break that down a little bit. Me
and my co-founder, partner in crime, Will Wise,
wrote a book called "Ask Powerful Questions:
Create Conversations That Matter" which is
a little bit to my surprise
continue to just like sit on a
best sellers list on Amazon. So, I'm gonna unpack
3 tools that we share in this book that we're
gonna say encapsulates The Road Trip Method.
So, by the end of this video, what's in my brain
about how to create conversations that matter
and how to bring up new topics in conversation
and keep a conversation filled with life and
energy and curiosity as opposed to this like
trailing, ending conversation with like, "So.." right?
And the attempts of avoiding that- and avoiding
that and maybe even more importantly, creating
conversations that are really valuable to you
and to the people that you're talking with. Number
1 is listen to the music behind the words, right.
So often when people say things, right, we take them
at face value. But, we're not a cop or a lawyer or
anybody else. We don't need to just hear the facts,
right. We can hear the depth behind what
somebody's saying. And so, some specific ways that
you can hear music behind the words because just
generally you could take that idea and skip to
the next section in the video, right. Just the
mindset of listening to the music behind the words
just recognizing that if somebody shows you this,
what they're actually saying is all filled
in the space in between as well. And so, it's the
unstated feelings that are happening. it's the
opinion that they're not quite sharing but is
sort of embedded, it's the process of how the
conversation is going, right. So, I work with
a lot of leaders that are very like me to some
extent, ADHD busy. And so, walking into their office
or hop on with them on Zoom and they're clearly
doing 17 other things, right. So, music behind the
words. They might be saying something but there
I can see all of this other stuff going on there.
So, listening to music behind the words increases
the amount of data that you get in a conversation
by at least 20 percent. Sort of an arbitrary number,
but thinking about road trips having,
you know, constant novel data coming at you at
70 miles per hour, listening to the music behind
the words increases the level of data that's in
the conversation. You've just got to tune into it,
right. Oftentimes we find what we're looking for
and we hear what we're listening for. So, if you're
just listening for the facts, you're just going to
hear the facts. If you're just listening for that
person to be annoying, that's all you're going to
hear. But, if you listen for their strengths, their
fears, their aspirations, the background, the whole
story, you're going to have a very, very different
conversation. Part number 2 of the road trip
method is you have to believe that conversation is
exponential. And what I mean by that is if you
ask- so, 1 of the 4 questions that often gets
asked in conversation when you first meet a person
like where are you from, what do you do, how are you.
Well, maybe just 3. And so, if you ask
"Where are you?" and that person says- where are
you? Oh my goodness, where are you from is a better
way of phrasing that. So, if you ask a person, "Where
are you from?" And they say "Massachusetts," right.
That's it. That is true. I am from Massachusetts,
but I don't live in Massachusetts, but I am
from there. I live in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania now.
And my social security number and address is just
kidding! If they just share Massachusetts, right,
even though they only gave you 1 word of data,
you might be able to tell were they excited to
show that they were from Massachusetts? Were they
completely indifferent? Did they share it in a way
of like. "I'm from Massachusetts," right.
Was there- is there hesitation? So, there's that
data. There's also just everything that you
know about Massachusetts and your experiences
with Massachusetts, and when I say conversation is
exponential, even though they share just 1 word,
the way they feel about Massachusetts, what
you're curious about Massachusetts and the prior
experiences that you've had in Massachusetts are
3, of many probably, but just 3 potential
pathways that you can continue on. So, if you
continue on this pathway, right, there may be
3 others that come out. And then 3 others
and then 3 others and then others.
And this is what I mean when I say, "Conversation
is exponential." The problem is when we're in the
moment and we're wondering how to bring up new
topics in conversation or how to continue a
really meaningful discussion, if we get
stuck at all, we get stuck and we think, "Oh,
there's nothing left to talk about." So, if I'm
on a date with my wife, Kate, and conversation
is going, going, going and then that topic sort
of just kind of fizzles or dies, we're going to
continue that dialogue in 2 very different
ways if I believe that conversation is exponential
versus if I think "Oh, there's nothing left to
talk about," right. We've been married for 7
years. We've talked about everything under the
sun that we can possibly talk about anything
else. That lit- that is an extremely limiting
belief that will prevent topic exploration
in conversation, whereas if I say even though we've
been talking for 30 minutes, and so I believe if
someone spoke for 30 minutes, you have at least
300 different pathways of potential conversation
if you're listening to the music behind
the words. And then the 3rd idea here
comes directly from Ask Powerful Questions and it
is this idea of asking reflective questions. So, you
can you know just pull questions out of thin air,
out of your own curiosity. Reflective questions
is a little bit different. It's where you reflect
what you've heard somebody else say and then ask
a question rooted in it. And you kind of get- you
feed 2 birds with one worm when you do that
because when you reflect what somebody else has
said it's like a mirror that illuminates something
to them, right. Oftentimes when we speak even as I'm
recording this video right now and speaking like
I can't hear myself talking and really process
that and think about what I'm going to say next.
So, when you reflect what somebody else says,
it illuminates what they're saying to them.
And oftentimes it's amazing like even if you
reflect verbatim, exactly what somebody else has
said, you reflect that back to them, it's amazing
how frequently someone will jump and be like, "No,
no. That's not what I mean." And then correct and
extend that conversation and get to the heart
of the matter. It's a phenomenal tool to create
conversations that matter to you and to the other
person. Now, a reflective question is you reflect a
piece of what somebody said and then add on
a question. Let's do this kind of odd in a video
format right now. So, we're having an interaction,
right you're watching a video which I've recorded
in the past and you're seeing it live now. So, if
I were to reflect right in this moment, I might
say, "Hey, it seems like you're watching this video.
You're getting toward the end. You must be enjoying
it to some degree. I'm wondering what has really
stuck out to you about this video." Did you
see it? That was a reflective question. I reflected
what was happening in this moment and then I added
on a question rooted in my own curiosity at the
end. And jumping back to number 2 with that
word "curiosity," conversation is exponential if,
if you are genuinely, naturally curious about
that person, that idea etc. The cool thing is
that natural, genuine curiosity is actually
a choice. It's not a gene, right. Curiosity-
you weren't just born with or without curiosity.
In fact, I would argue that we're all born with an
immense amount of curiosity and if you've ever met
a 3 to 5 year old, you know that that's true.
And so, we lose touch with that curiosity a little
bit as time goes on. But, we still can choose to
flip it on. And so, to channel The Road Trip Method
and make a road trip level quality conversation
happen in a classroom, a board room, a living room,
anywhere else, listen to the music behind the words.
Believe that conversation is exponential and
ask really great reflective questions rooted
in your own curiosity. I'm Chad Littlefield. It
was awesome hanging out in cyberspace with you.
If you want a free digital version of "Ask Powerful
Questions," there's a link below to download a ton of
free resources along with a bunch of conversation
topic questions that I created in a deck called "We
Connect" cards and a whole ton of other resources
that will help you create conversations that
matter. And just in case you were wondering what
my brother drives, it is a nice, shiny, green lambo
Kia soul! Have an awesome day.